well we're joined now by the foreign
office minister james cleverley thanks
very much for joining us this morning
uh why on earth is this taking so long
it was one week the government announces
that they're going to do it the next
week this week we're discovering that
they're only just talking to hotels
they're going to
set out the plans next week and then
it's going to be the following week
before passengers can actually get into
these hotels
well we should remember that the package
that we
have announced that will come into force
on the 15th of february
adds to our existing package of measures
to protect ourselves at the borders
people could you should remember that
for the most part people shouldn't be
traveling
at all anyway if somewhere however sorry
but
there are one and a half thousand people
it's estimated coming from these red
list countries that's what the hotels
are being told to plan for so clearly a
huge number of people
are still coming into the uk from all of
these countries that we've said that we
didn't want people to come to the uk
from
at the moment if if that is happening on
a daily basis
why take a month to implement something
well as matt hancock said in in your
in your clip we need time to prepare we
need time to make sure
that this works that's why uh we've
given the hotel industry
a notice to give them time to prepare to
train staff and to get there
to get their rooms ready for a very
different type
of um but surely this doesn't take a
month i mean
i mean come on you know you say you need
a you need them time to prepare
best western their uh head spoke
yesterday he said they hadn't even been
contacted yesterday if he
ran his company like the government was
running this he would have lost his
job i mean it is relatively
straightforward isn't it you put people
in a hotel
uh you make them stay in a room you
deliver food three times a day it
doesn't take a month to organize
well we've been we've been working with
uh international partners who have put a
similar
uh package in place new zealand
australia for example to see how that
works
it's very easy for you to say oh all you
have to do is
but uh hindsight is is a wonderful thing
and actually
um as i say this is this is adding to
an existing package of measures which
requires
a uh a test before uh departure
requires a notification form upon
departure
already requires 10 days of quarantine
so this is adding to existing measures
and we want to make sure that this works
that we give the hotel industry
notice obviously not every hotel will be
doing this and so it's unsurprising that
some hotel chains haven't been
contacted about this but the uh the the
package we're putting together uh this
quarantine package adds to an existing
suite of measures
to protect ourselves at the border you
say we're talking to
to our counterparts like australia and
new zealand um
the health minister didn't talk to
australia his australian counterpart
until yesterday
still hasn't spoken as far as we're
aware to new zealand about it i mean
they've been doing this
for months surely they've got a template
wouldn't the first thing to do would be
on the first date to phone new zealand
phone australia
how have you done it what's the template
let's get it underway in a few days
well as i say we are we are uh working
with international partners
on this as we have slowly and actually
and actually
the um the uk has been
uh the uk has been coordinating our
response to coronavirus internationally
just as
all countries have done but i think it's
you know i i'll reinforce the point that
this is adding to
an existing suite of measures
that already sees a requirement for
testing before arrival
quarantine on arrival this is
strengthening an already strong set of
border measures and and
and it needs to be seen in that context
okay um
let's get back to that red list one and
a half thousand people a day in theory
coming in um why are we letting one and
a half thousand people in why are we
letting anybody in why do we
why doesn't everybody have to either go
to a hotel or just not come to the uk
well we we've um already said
that uh travel should be minimized that
figure
is uh is not an audit of the number of
people who have come
it is a it is a planning assumption for
the hotel industry to
to work around i say we've already got
very uh um
effective measures including a
moratorium on travelling
if people arrive from those countries
and they shouldn't do
we have enforcement measures at the
border which
which could be up to including them
being returned back to the
place of origin those people could be
but but it doesn't mean they they will
be
stopped and what's to stop them at the
moment going via a different
country uh the point the point we're
making
is that um because we are
insisting on uh a pre-departure test we
know which country people are coming
from there is already a requirement that
they quarantine
uh when they arrive and for those people
like british nationals for example
coming from those countries
uh that that can't be um refused entry
at the borders
there are already there is already a
requirement that
they quarantine this is about enhancing
enhancing
that quarantine requirement do you think
setting out separate countries
is really a very useful policy because
if we look back to the to the first
lockdown
china you know seen as the source only
only one percent of those who came in
to the uk um were from china 62
were from france and spain so actually
it was countries that we didn't know
where the virus was that actually
theoretically brought it to the uk so
you know in a sense is this policy much
use anyway
well comparing what we're doing now with
what happened at the start
um is is not that relevant we understand
we learn lessons from the past we we
learn
we indeed we but we also know a huge
deal more now
about uh where in the world the virus uh
is uh prevalent uh where variants of the
virus
are currently uh being detected and our
own genomic research program is helping
the world better understand
the nature of this virus so we better
understand
now uh where the greatest risk
is where the uh where the requirement
for
quarantine uh is is most effective
we didn't the world no one in the world
knew as much about the virus then
as we know about the virus now so
comparing the situation now to the
situation
uh in the past really is not that useful
okay let's let's get
more into the nuts and bolts of how
it'll actually work um someone comes to
the uk
uh they've come from a red list country
how do they get to the hotel
well there'll be a transporter range
these are details that will
uh will be shared with the uh with the
ports with the hotel
authorities between now and the go live
date these are the things where you say
these although the point is these are
the logistic things because it won't be
the same in every instance
these these are the kind of logistics
that we have to get right and so earlier
on we said
all you have to do is well actually as
you can see as soon as you start looking
at the detail of implementing this
it's really important that the border
officials the ports and the receiving
hotels are all coordinated
on this including things like travel
that's why we're giving notice
that's why we're working with the
industry to make sure that this is
effective when it's brought in
and the government's going to be paying
for it initially why is that because
most other countries
that that do this immediately put on to
the travelers i mean if they can't
afford to pay
for the hotel for the quarantine they
shouldn't be coming here surely
well we've already made the point that
that unless there is a very very good
reason
a very limited set of reasons that
people shouldn't be traveling
uh at all we want to make sure that this
is implemented
um effectively right from the get-go
which is why we're giving notice which
is why we're working
with with the industry let's say we
learn lessons from international
partners it doesn't mean to say we'll
replicate what they do
in every instance but this is about
making
that we beef up as i say the the sweeter
measures that we've already got in place
to protect ourselves from the
international spread of this virus
do you think it should be a blanket
policy acro across the whole of the uk
because
because you know obviously scotland's
expressed concerns clearly anybody could
at the moment be coming into heathrow
and then traveling up to scotland well
as i say we know so much more about uh
where the vaccine is most prevalent
uh we know so much more about um how
the vaccine is traveling internationally
uh we don't feel
uh that a a blanket moratorium is
effective and what we have done is we
have
we have used uh the knowledge that we
have got
uh from our coordinated work with
international partners
to focus on the areas of of most risk
so that we have a an effective and
balanced approach because
you know blanket coverage um would
would would mean that we would be
forcing
these measures on people coming from
countries potentially with very very low
uh case numbers uh and that would that
would
potentially be counterproductive so
we've focused on the areas that we know
to be uh of the most problematic okay i
haven't got my jungler so
let's crack on and staying with travel
holidays and vaccine passports
uh in the papers today that the
government is now thinking it is a good
idea after saying it wasn't
has the science changed or is this
another government u-turn
sorry on what so i didn't catch on on
vaccine passports the possibility of
people getting a vaccine passport to
go to places like greece this summer
well
ultimately the border measures of of
other countries and
and what they require of people coming
to their countries will be
will be up to them one of the things
that we are seeing now
is the the uk is one of the leading
countries in the world
over ten and a half million people
vaccinated twenty percent
of a uk adults vaccinated so we're
seeing
that our a world-class vaccine program
is really giving us uh um uh positive
news
but ultimately sorry that isn't what
we're asking about though it's about
whether or not we should be should we
actually have a vaccine passport to
allow us to travel
well as i'm saying it wasn't a good idea
and now it seems to be thinking it is
what the point i'm making is is is
receiving countries will set their own
border measures
um and it will be it will be up to those
countries to define
what they require travellers to have
at the moment most countries including
our own require a
negative test result and we'll have to
see what what countries what the
international community put in place
once uh vaccines around the world
are as you know as effectively
distributed as they are here in the uk
in terms of thinking of things across
the whole uk what about schools
wales and scotland are already saying
school's going to go back on the 22nd
uh england northern ireland still
holding back for the 8th of march we
know that one
scientist on the nerve tag committee has
said that it that it's a political
calculation now more than a scientific
one
why can't khan schools in england go
back after half term
well we have uh we have said that we are
going to review the epidemiological
situation um we are we are we
we make our decisions about schools and
other things
guided by the science so we want to
basically see
uh what the effect of our lack on the
nhs is
like before we make a final decision so
so we've
said that we will take stock of the
situation on the 15th of feb
that will guide our decisions and then
uh
the government could roll back and say
schools go back after half term they
could make that call on the 15th
it doesn't give schools much time does
it well the the uh the reason that we
are taking
a uh an audit of the situation on the
15th
is so that we can uh if the situation is
is positive and
um and and it seems like i don't i don't
want to run ahead of
uh of circumstances but it seems things
are heading in the right direction
and if that continues if it gets the
place where it is safe to do so
we will then give schools enough notice
that they can organize themselves to
reopen
but the decision will be made based on
the scientific evidence which is
assessed on the 15th of february
okay james cleverley thank you very much
for joining us this morning